kingdom is a Korean zombie period piece
that definitely deserves your attention
whilst the show initially flew under the
radar upon release the six episode
horror drama is a masterpiece throughout
this video I'll be discussing everything
that you need to know about Kingdom and
its ending so there will of course be
heavy spoilers this show is by far the
best that Netflix of / out in January so
I highly recommend that you give it a
full watch if you haven't seen it yet
without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I watch it
so you don't have to after the king
falls ill with wise believed to be
smallpox the throne comes into
contention whilst naturally his son at
the crown prince would inherit this
there is conflict caused due to the fact
that the queen is pregnant and about to
give birth if the king does not die
until that child is born and then it
shall rightfully be the next heir due to
the crown prince's illegitimate sea the
queen is the daughter of a Senate member
who lusts for power and wants his
grandson to be ruler of the nation this
Senate member named Cho is the main
antagonist and whilst this story is set
to the backdrop of the show it is it's
driving force after the crown prince he
is a monster roaming the halls of the
kingdom he sets out on a mission that
involves committing high treason in
order to claim his birthright and find
out what's wrong with his father he
travels to Dorne where he discovers a
starving village mistakingly
cannibalized the body that had been
victim to the king and thus it caused
the disease to spread amongst them that
rapidly kills and makes them rise from
the dead
the zombies are seemingly nocturnal and
in daylight appear like normal corpses
this forces an investigation on what has
happened to them as on discovery in the
day it appears to be a massacre
however we learn that it is actually the
temperature that stops them from
attacking and if it is cool enough then
they will rise from the dead which plays
into the show's ending the crown prince
learns that this disease is actually
caused by a rare herb called the
resurrection plant which has been used
on the king to make it appear that he is
still alive until the baby is born of
course keeping a group of the undead
around isn't a wise move and when they
are brought into a city through the
day time things go awry at night we get
a fantastic prison scene and the whole
ravaged the majority of the population
that lived there personally I view this
as a metaphor for the class struggle
that we often see in real life the rich
noblemen are points throughout the show
have vast banquets and beats whilst the
poor starve this show can be seen as the
hungry majority rising up to consume the
full minority I can't express how
outstanding the first horde attack is
and it really shocked me too just how
unique this show was it managed to flip
the zombie genre on its head and its
setting as a period piece it's an
inspired choice by the show's close we
have a final standoff with the crown
prince who has found his old master the
crown prince leads a group of peasants
after softening to their plight on the
other side of this is the senator who
wants to keep control of power after his
son's death he brings a group of zombies
to the Crown Prince and this is an
incredible last set piece that involves
the undead being able to attack due to
the freezing cold temperature just as it
looks like things are about to heat up
in a final showdown Kingdom does a big
fu to the audience and cuts to the
credits in what is one of the most
devastating cliffhangers ever in terms
of the crown prince's claim to the
throne we actually learned that the
Queen had had a miscarriage and is no
longer pregnant whilst the cause of this
is never fully confirmed one could
imagine that it is due to the stress
that is caused by her undead husband
becoming a monster we learn that there
are a group of pregnant women in the
palace and this to me signifies that
there are other plans for the air we
also discovered that there is a mole
within the crown prince's group and no
it is never confirmed I would imagine it
to be his loyal bodyguard as he has been
put closest to the king and will be able
to keep a watchful eye on his movement
overall I thought the show was
phenomenal and it's definitely one of
the most interesting zombie premises
we've ever got the acting was superb and
I highly recommend watching this with
the original audio as you don't really
get all of the nuances in the dialogue
from the subtitled version of course I'd
love to hear your thoughts on Kingdom
and whether you enjoyed the show or not
if you liked this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out my breakdown of this week's of the
big zombie release Resident Evil 2
remake which would be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
heavy into horror so if that's the kind
of thing you like it subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace